[Musique]
le cfc avec alim benzema première soit
il qui est exprimée depuis très
longtemps
le couac de l'année c'est marine le pen
lors du débat de l'autre sont
essentielles
sa macro elle s'est complètement à
utiliser avec ses fils et ses gestes
chez vous celui-ci medef
neymar est âgée de 122 millions voici
tes se bat là ok en prime le dr logis
mon équipe et moi même mené par
l'excellente eddine grégory avons gagné
aux brodeuses
la date de cette année c'est février
2017 et à gâteau proulx qu'évoquer
magnifique très sympathique des
journalistes
[Applaudissements]
oui benjamin castaldi sais pas si pour
régler des problèmes gastriques
[Musique]